yeah welcome to this video and why why
am I getting a three minute game hmm
okay I actually I was pretty sure to
have clicked on five minute but now for
some reason um at some it three minutes
okay I set up a Schliemann here to sort
of increase the pace of this game maybe
I'm get some early confrontation going
it doesn't doesn't seem to have already
made answer yeah this is the modern main
line and now Queenie to black has
alternatives but this is the only in
variation I really know him take some
night f6 GF 64 Bishop g7 it's the line
that I know a bit at least aha I wasn't
even aware that this is a move always
interesting okay so let's let's take
here he can of course do this but at the
end I've got two pieces to pieces sum
for rook of course he's got a couple of
pounds but I've got potentially very
very active pieces d3 just cancels and
then if then look at this I mean if a
night on on e4 bishop on g6 and I'll put
this Bishop on c6 so I have a battery of
Queen and and Bishop on the long
diagonal it's hard for him to to play
without f3 here for the long run at
least the question is how to proceed no
I don't think I have some something
instantly
and also yeah there's always this Quincy
4hu so i probably need to spend one move
to get the King out of out of this this
check possibility yeah maybe it's e5 you
want some place in five it also controls
d 50 may be a good move probably he will
go every 2 to UM to blunt this diagonal
okay let's um let's take the pawn if he
goes f3 yeah as usual my moose I ignore
time I know that I already and I thought
I would just take here now after taking
on c5 I've got this year and this looks
quite dangerous to me Quincy a g-force
Quincy 883 I really thought he needs to
react to to this attack how does it
prevent Quincy for now or queen h3 I
mean both moves are are pretty a pretty
direct and strong
you can play quindi for to cover to
cover 3g for but then i go to h3 and
next move as he resides probably so what
now just rook takes a phone guess so
looks like the easiest solution yeah he
needed to react i mean at least i just
four seconds for the smooth I don't know
g2 a sound detect I think this is really
really dangerous now uh-huh computer
doesn't agree he thinks Bishop takes c5
s is equal now interesting yeah in a
three minute came difficult to calculate
but this is winning okay this this
losses for white we sure got three wins
computer gives this as equal Bishop
takes d5 interesting let's check the
score clippership f3 Queen III and now
Quincy eight you won't go here yeah okay
maybe you can still still threatening
this our queen here okay and this way
you cover all this and now I can take on
on d1 and on c4 with an equal position
or maybe slight advantage for black
button sir nothing special okay yeah but
writer and now he gives rook f6 and
winning for black button okay
Gurudev sexy six minutes dangerous of
course probably still winning yeah it's
it's really you need you need to spend
at least a bit of time before you're
allowed Bishop takes g2 learning you can
play f3 I mean this is not a big deal
just done I was expecting on just this
move and down yeah okay Queenie 8 is a
good good answer that I probably
wouldn't have played quick eh to e5 I
was more thinking about night here to 2f
for this is maybe nothing special for
black yeah thanks for watching this game
I intend to the five-minute game but got
three at the end still interesting
thanks for watching